this morning in our series i on earth we
look at how working from home is
affecting the environment
when people all over the world don't go
to the office there are fewer cars on
the road
that's good for stopping air pollution
but a recent
u.n report found an unexpected 7
drop in emissions this year will have an
insignificant effect on the overall
global warming trend
mark phillips shows how working from
home can actually
impact the planet more than you may
realize
for a lot of us in these covid times the
morning commute has developed into its
own new routine
fighting all that traffic down the
hallway and
into the home office but if there's one
consolation to this new way of life
it's a feeling that however solitary it
may be better for the planet
we are after all producing a lot less of
the global warming greenhouse gases that
we used to
by spewing our way to work in our cars
and then spending our days in power
hungry offices
well hold the smugness working from home
is not
cost free and the more of us who do it
the more environmentally expensive
it becomes every email and text
especially the unnecessary little ones
every
thank you and got it every time we hit
send
or download or stream or zoom
they all require power somewhere massive
banks of computers are storing and
processing that data
sucking up enormous amounts of
electrical energy to do
it the cloud doesn't so much have a
silver lining
as a carbon one i mean it's it's
certainly
good for the planet to save your commute
but
mike berners-lee who has written on the
carbon cost of everything
says it's not that simple but on the
other hand
if you're at home with the heating on
which it wouldn't otherwise have to be
then that's not so good and you're
probably using more
computing stuff than you would be think
about it
every email we send not only requires
electricity to write
as it travels across the internet it
gets stored
and transferred from one mega server to
another
gobbling up energy along the way then if
it gets red
it sucks up even more power an email may
use just five percent of the power
needed to deliver a paper letter
but we send and receive gazillions of
them
someone here has actually done the math
and figured that if everyone in britain
sent one less thank you
email a day the carbon saving would be
like taking about three and a half
thousand cars off the road
admittedly it's just a rough calculation
but the principle
is accurate i t is a huge consumer of
power
and it's growing exponentially many more
people
are emailing and receiving emails if so
many more people are streaming
if the cloud becomes that much bigger
and requires that much more storage
isn't that creating an energy hungry
infrastructure yeah it really it is and
we you know we
estimate that the whole of information
communication technology
is probably responsible for somewhere
between two and four percent
of the whole world's carbon footprint
right and that's
that's a big deal and it's becoming a
bigger deal
maybe the question we need to be asking
is do i really need to send this
for cbs this morning i'm
mark phillips in london
so i looked it up it's actually a lot
less energy use if you text someone
so if you can get it down under 160
characters it uses a lot less energy
just don't send the gif or gif however
you want to say it
or you know anything else that could use
up some more energy yeah and i know with
lab you were working from home for so
long i mean you actually had a crew
yeah we had a crew we had lights we had
cameras uh and
the electric bill was a little higher
than it normally is
have you expensed that yet i have not oh
i think we should work on that
i probably shouldn't get on a lot of
energy though it does it does take a lot
of energy and
you know it's important to think that
whenever you've got a positive which
some people might find working from home
a positive
there's a negative and it's on the
environment yeah